I think one of the most touching things
about seeing the children at the funeral
was the little horseshoe Broach that
Charlotte was wearing on her coat and we
understand this was gifted her from the
queen it's just so perfect it was it was
small it was meaningful it signified the
Queen's love of horses and I'm sure
there will be other pieces that we'll
see over the years that the queen has
left for her great-granddaughter but it
was again that sense of continuity and
sentimental value attached to pieces of
jewelry like that that signal how close
the queen clearly was I think there was
a Sentimental side to the queen and I
think um you know she was very keen to
have those pieces that probably had
great meaning to her in the horse she
would have been you know it's a very
sweet gesture because of the Queen's
love of horses and she wanted those
pieces passed down and specifically that
piece to princess Charlotte I think you
know as the Prince of Wales said in his
statement he he felt hugely grateful
that his family got to spend so much
time with the queen I mean Kate had 20
years to really get to know the Monarch
what a privilege as a future Queen
consort hugely important as well but not
just that the queen had a lot of time
with her great grandchildren the queen
would Host this wonderful sleepover at
Balmoral in August and invite all of the
grandchildren and the great
grandchildren and she looked forward to
that weekend I think probably more than
any other it was always noisy when
Prince Philip was still alive he made
sure he wasn't around because there were
too many screaming children but the
queen absolutely loved it and I think
it was massively important to her that
she got to spend that time with her
family
[Music]
[Music]